le président de la république tout petit
déjà françois se voyait président de la
république toute sa vie il n'a eu que ça
en tête toute sa vie il a préparé en
secret avec ses meilleurs amis ce moment
tant attendu son élection à la tête du
pays
comme lui avant nicolas y pensait depuis
tout petit pareil pour jacques avant
nicolas
il faut dire que pour devenir président
de la république il faut sacrément être
sûr de sa force et croire en soi parce
que le président de la république c'est
le successeur des rois de france et a
beaucoup de pouvoir pas autant que les
rois quand même mais bien plus que de
nombreux chefs d'état étrangers
on dit même que la france est une
monarchie républicaine
c'est la cinquième république depuis
1958 mise en place par le général de
gaulle qui en a décidé ainsi
avant sous la quatrième république le
président n'avait pas beaucoup de
pouvoir on disait pour se moquer de lui
qu'il inaugurait les chrysanthèmes qu'il
passait son temps à décorer des anciens
combattants le général de gaulle
trouvais qu'il fallait un vrai chef
parce qu'en france on adore discuter
politique et se disputer on n'est pas
très disciplinés comme peuple alors il
faut qu'un chef avec beaucoup de
pouvoirs soit à la tête de l'état parce
que comment voulez vous gouverner un
pays où il existe 300 sortes de fromages
seulement voilà comme nous sommes en
démocratie
si l'on donne beaucoup de pouvoir un
seul homme il faut qu'il soit élu
directement par le peuple
tous les cinq ans on procède donc à
l'élection présidentielle le nom de ce
mode d'élection est très compliqué
suffrage uninominal direct à deux tours
mais en vrai c'est très simple comme
élections un électeur égale une voix
ça se déroule sur 2 dimanche le premier
dimanche on vote pour le candidat de son
choix
le deuxième dimanche ont choisi entre
les deux finalistes
donc celui qui fait plus de 50% est élu
le président nomme un premier ministre
et les ministres
il nomme aussi des préfets dans chaque
région et des ambassadeurs dans chaque
pays il est responsable de la défense
nationale des relations avec tous les
autres pays de la planète
il fixe les grandes orientations et
décide presque seul si la france par
exemple va continuer à faire des
centrales nucléaires ou plutôt des
éoliennes
le soir du réveillon il nous parle à la
télé les yeux dans les yeux parce que
c'est notre chef
le président de la république il est à
droite ou à gauche ça dépend mais comme
ils représentent tous les français je
dois faire attention de ne pas trop
pencher d'un côté ou de l'autre comme il
nous représente il est très protégé par
la garde républicaine et des tas de
gardes du corps surentraînés il vit
aussi dans un certain apparat sous les
dorures du palais de l'élysée on est
quand même en france alors si toi aussi
tu rêves comme jacques nicolaou françois
de devenir un jour président ou
présidente il n'y en a jamais eu du
travail plutôt à être bon élève à te
faire le plus de copains possible parce
que le chemin est long avant d'atteindre
l'elysée est tu n'es pas seul à tenter l
aventure